et je voudrais commencer par vous
présenter cette dame on va la baptiser
un moulin est parmi nous envoyer toutes
les personnes qui vivent en milieu rural
donc environ 51% de la population
je suis patricia ziahé
je me décris comme étant une solution au
problème et une entrepreneur dans l'âme
parce que j'ai appris ce métier auprès
de ma mère
dès l'âge de 5 ans déjà mais ma mère il
aime toujours même si elle est de
l'autre côté et je suis entre dans ce
milieu là parce que j'ai l'honneur et je
voulais l'aider dans ses tâches
quotidiennes et donc je passais mon
temps entre les études le commerce de ma
mère et ma mère elle était vendeuse
ambulante noël années de village en
village et elle faisant son kaunas
j'étais passionné par les deux choses
que je faisais donc j'arrive à exceller
et dans mes études et dans le commerce
de ma mère donc je finis mes études de
droit à l'essai de science politique de
ouagadougou
j'ai à peine 21 ans et j'ai décidé
d'être entrepreneur tout de suite j'ai
pas cherché à travailler
cela m'intéressait de déposer un cv dans
une entreprise s'était pas encore à
l'époque en entrepreneuriat est aussi
mis à la page on pas l'entrepreneuriat
c'était en 99 à 4 98
mon père c'était le premier choc il
voulait que je continue dans une
carrière de diplomate comme vie je
voulais pas en fait est le deuxième choc
m'a béni du fait que je vais devenir que
la met en avant des les villages pour
ceux qui connaissent un peu nos villages
on appelle ça le logo du goût c'est des
femmes qui jouent de marché en train dé
bretagne ont et vont me faire le marché
on plaide il n'y a pas dans le gard et
je me plaisais à faire ce et donc pour
la phase de chaud de l'entrepreneur jeu
à l'époque il y avait les cabines
téléphoniques avec les chargeurs sont
jamais de la vie de soubré une
quarantaine de tapis téléphonique que je
jouerai et voilà que l'âme et relations
avec les populations du monde rural
je me rends compte que elles sont
confrontées à un problème avoir accès
aux transferts d'argent et donc c'est de
là que par mon histoire mais déjà avec
trois ans j'avais déjà deux entreprises
et jean prêts déjà lu quarantaine de
personnes
dans cet arrêt le double de mon âge et
c'était pas ma première et l'échangé de
biens s'est déroulée je peux m'exprimer
ici jusqu'à anjou ce point d'autres
catastrophes mais entreprises c'est con
j'ai plus d'argent je touche le fond je
touche vraiment le fond est là
je commence à ne plus vouloir rien faire
parce que j'avais peur de l'échec
donc pour moi je voulais rester à ne
rien faire
je n'ai pas d'essayer quelque chose
d'essayer à nouveau et là je commence à
me motiver je vais je lis bélisle de
motivation mais rien ne me motive à
faire quelque chose je regardais vidéo
de jabal il échoue et neuf mille fois je
lis tous les livres de motivation le
rien
le déclic va arriver en 2009 ma mère
était décédée une année avant et pendant
que je romps ses affaires je tombe sur
une photo et cette photo laraque et le
déclic en moi donc ce que tous les
grands hommes de ce monde n'ont pas pu
faire pour me mettre débout sais je suis
une photo et je vous raconte l'histoire
de cette peau qui se rappelle de sa plus
belle histoire d'amour
[Musique]
loc voilà donc tout le monde a une plus
belle histoire d'amour
[Musique]
donc quand j'étais démérité ensuite en
licence j'aidais ma mère à vendre et ma
mère faisait ce qu'on appelle énorme on
vous dit voilà donc on se retrouve et de
mon cou 10 et le monde aient de l'eau
glacée et j'ai remporté la glacière ce
matin pour aller à la boutique deux
premiers des rondes et vous savez qu'on
nous arriver un âge on va commencer à
voir le regard des hommes sont positives
ou et que vous commencez à tomber
amoureuse ça sans peur de porter la
glacière de passer devant tout le monde
et il amène un brin des malheureux qui
n'avaient pas digéré son échec
ils étaient limités si ça et chansons
que j'ai passé ma glace hier il se
moquait la vendeuse de glaces et il ya
de la glace et et ça me frustrait jamais
comment ça vanne pause et ma mère qui
avait fait mater cette gêne la map les
dans sa chambre je pouvais rien à sa
manière je continue de le faire mais je
suis pas à l'aise je le fais parce que
j'avais peur et on appelle aux achats et
on lui dit ma fille est et conviction
ep conviction ne regarde pas ce que les
réponses de toi vittavi et pour
m'encourager me dis chaque fois que tu
reviens de la vente de digne mon coude
ou un papa plus belle robe tu te sens je
prends une photo
et puis plus tard cette photo là tu vas
la retaper enfants et voilà corps dans
les affaires de ma mère je tombe sur
cette photo efe que le déclic s'est tous
les grands auteurs de ce monde n'avait
pas plus criants moi maman venait de
crier et je me rendais compte mais dans
que les limites sont plus mental
physique et qu'est ce que je vais faire
je vais décider de repos je décide de
mettre en place une société qui va
permettre aux populations de d'envoyer
de l'argent mais je fais mon business
planning le show de 300 millions ou
quelqu'un qui n'a plus rien qui a des
dettes et comment je commence et donc il
n'est les six que j'ai commencé par
faire c'est sous la forme d'un foulard
attachez mon visage je ne vois personne
avec mes convictions ne pas le laisser
intimider par le regard des autres donc
je commence mon entreprise et je
commence avec 60 microns ses fins
j'achète un ordinateur 3e 4e main et un
téléphone je commence à travers la
maison et je travaillais et conjuguer
amour haine on me prenait pour une
personne qui était folle parce qu'à
l'époque il y avait les grandes
compagnies de transfert d'argent
européenne occidentale et on me demande
comment je pouvais les concurrencer joly
juge pas les concurrencer
g schaffhouse ou d'un besoin que j'ai
que j'ai vu au milieu du palm moi je
sais pas ce que c'est que la concurrence
j'ai un rêve et je vis et j'ai commencé
à rêver
[Musique]
c'est le plus bel exercice que je sais
faire rêver et tous les jours je rêve et
je rêve pas en couleur comme fait il
maïs est la plus belle image que j'ai
sur mon ordinateur mon front il voit ses
pivots tu voyais qu'ils influent oki
d'appui il amputé mais benoît seppi et
donc je commence à rêver et quand je
rêve je rêve c'est fou cette fois j'ai
dit mon rêve fait peur et camarades ne
peux pas je me dis je suis sur le bon
chemin et j'aurais dû changer le monde
et je pense que je peux le faire je vais
transformer des vies notamment les vies
des populations qui vivent en milieu
rural
et ça c'est mon rêve c'est pourquoi
depuis le 1er janvier
j'ai quitté la direction de 8 h j'étais
confiant collaborateurs qu aller en
milieu rural pour patty à 0 et bâti
quelque chose là parce que c'est mon
rêve
mon rêve c'est de nourrir l'afrique et
et attax mots qui sont qui font que je
n'ai plus de limites
tout d'abord essayé je sais toujours un
pote le résultat je me dis que je vais
échoué donc c'est pas un problème pour
moi
l'échec ça n'existe pas ça fait partie
de mon parcours et je me dis que
finalement je vais apprendre et quand je
vais apprendre je vais réussi et à
partir de ce moment toutes les limites
ce qui pouvait se poser dans ma vie ont
sauté voici et je prends plaisir moi
aller dans ce monde milieu rural a parlé
avec les populations
et c'est là que je me sens respecte
j'emmène mes enfants si là je ne sont
pas heureux dans six mois dans un bar
parce que je me sens heureux quand je
suis en milieu rural en bottes au milieu
des paysans et lorsque je travaille
véritablement avec eux et lui ai donc
mon rêve le rêve fou de jeu patins c'est
de nourrir l'afrique parce que pour moi
il est passé un poney plus de la moitié
des terres et que au nom n'est pas de la
devanture
donc je vais mettre de la nourriture
dans chaque plat d'une africaine se
mourait
je vais jouer ma fille en chansons le
monde rural avec un modèle économique
qui est le commerce équitable
nos paysans ils sont toujours courageux
mais n'ont jamais passé à l'au delà
la gamme et continuer à cultiver sont
mis les plus absolus mais n'a jamais
pensé à étendre à une échelle plus gros
et ce serait bien que je partage avec
ces femmes et je rêve là pour moi que je
pense que je dois pouvoir faire et c'est
pour ça que je me suis mis totalement
entièrement à disposition pour pouvoir
mettre cela en place
transformer la vie des et isa buteur de
pour ce faire j'ai créé mon propre
langage
les dictionnaires larousse ça ne me
concerne pas le petit bébé ça ne
concerne pas tout ce qui est que ça ne
concerne pas j'ai mon propre
dictionnaire et m'ont dit ça mais il est
dynamique dont j'ai la dalle en fonction
des situations
quand le talent et leur il peut changer
et nous donnerons du panel les chefs des
succès comme le soleil a pas de problème
il ya des solutions c'est ce que dit ce
n'est là que je partage avec toutes les
places ont tous mes collaborateurs et
dont genou on a commencé par changer le
langage et langage nouveau on n'a pas de
langage pessimiste ou optimiste
et ce dictionnaire je le mets à joue
avec beaucoup la montée en force des
qualifs
si on se rate en hauteur sur lola n'est
pas suffisamment fois on est chose c'est
pas la vie que c'est pas le collant
c'est nous qui l'avons écrit donc on
peut également adapter à la situation
j'ai commencé avec conté positif
positive et une bddp des plus belles
choses que je fais c'est de souris y'a
rien tu peux résister aux souris genova
souris s'il vous plaît merci et la
passion je me suis rendu comme de la
passion des choses inimaginables
je suis passionnée et quand je veux
quelque chose je le fais avec passion
quand je suis en milieu rural jeu je
suis avec passe juste y avait pas
souhaitable la passion des bilans pour
ce que je fais et ceux dont c'est pour
cela que chaque fois que je reviens
collaborateurs je n'aurai pas le diplôme
ou pour moi le diplôme c'est une
conjonction de connaissances est-ce
qu'il est passionné est-ce qu'il est
passionné être les façonner le cv n'est
pas quelque chose que je regarde c'est
la passion je regarde pas choisi mes
collaborateurs et bambou fini je
voudrais rendre hommage à ces femmes
qui sont ma motivation et qui vous amène
à l'au delà de mes limites je n'étais
enchaîné moi même alors que j'avais la
force d'un cheval face à une chaise qui
pouvaient tomber tout seul avec elle et
la première dame c'est ma mère et je
voudrais lui rendre hommage aux
instituts au ciel je te salue le geste
est aussi 18 et la bible images sur mon
image fétiche l'avons fait ce travail a
un drôle de rebih avec des femmes
et chaque fois que j'ai oublié pression
qu'on doit abandonner
j'ai dit non pour seulement se sourient
ou seulement 1 se sourient ça vaut la
peine d'être sans limite et je suis sans
illusion en doute est sans limite
parce qu'il vient de démarrer
[Applaudissements]